the shadow is the part of you that you
don't want other people to know about
it's the sort of conglomeration of your
insecurities your fears your perceived
inferiorities those parts of you because
they are parts of you were created when
you felt betrayed as a kid or you felt
abandoned or you felt abused or you felt
neglected or you were bullied at school
the reason why the shadow is so
important is because this is the
psychological material that gets in the
way of your goals and your aims and your
trajectory and what you want to build
and what you want to create and the type
of relationships that you want to have
the shadow is the part of you that
sabotages that that gets in the way it's
like no you don't deserve that now
you're not worthy Or Nah you should stay
up until three o'clock in the morning
and get you faced and you know show up
to that that big presentation that
important meeting with that client
hungover as hell